emails just released by the foreign
office show that boris johnson did order
the evacuation of animals from
afghanistan as thousands of afghans
tried to flee the taliban the animals
were being looked after by the nazad
charity which was formed by the former
royal marine penfaving
asked about their welfare last august
the prime minister said he'd exerted no
influence over the situation whatsoever
i've had absolutely no influence on any
particular case nor would that be uh
right that's not that's not how we do
things in this country but what i can i
can certainly say is that uh all what we
will certainly make sure is that uh and
there have been some heart-rending cases
i've just been looking at uh some of the
emails that have been coming in from
people in in afghanistan who have helped
us to whom we owe these these debts of
honor and obligation and it's it's
fantastic to see the way uh that we're
we're helping them but we've got to do
it uh impartially and uh and that's what
that's what we're doing and as i say we
we've so far thanks to this
extraordinary operation uh we've helped
the the overwhelming majority of people
in in both the categories and we're
going to use the remaining
time to do as many more as we possibly
can
well the prime minister they're saying
very clearly that he had no influence
over that decision what what has been
released today well this all relates
back to august of last year when you'll
remember there was that rapid evacuation
of british citizens and people have
helped british soldiers from kabul and
there was a big controversy at the time
that stretched over many months about
the decision to evacuate the individual
called penn fathing who ran an animal
charity
and the predominantly dogs that he had
with him
there were allegations at the time that
boris johnson personally ordered this uh
suggestion was that his wife carrie
johnson knows some of the people who are
close to penn farthing
and uh that the
top prime ministerial couple uh in some
way intervened and this was absolutely
firmly denied at the time it was denied
repeatedly by downing street it was
denied by boris johnson himself who said
no that's complete nonsense and it's
because because obviously the
the supposition is those dogs were
taking up spaces on planes of humans
i think the argument that it came down
to was that the amount of effort it was
going to take to get these animals onto
the runway
was
potentially
crowding out the space and the ability
of british elders and others to help
others from leaving the country
so a firm denial from danny street last
year but here's an email that's just
emerged from august of last year now
it's from zach goldsmith i think we can
take a look at it at the moment
uh and it's an email from that zack
culture who's a very close ally of uh
carrie johnson and boris johnson and it
says the pm has just authorized their
staff and animals of this charity to be
evacuated very uh clear there uh that
there's an instruction from
uh the prime minister now this matters
today because a lot about what we're
talking about what kirsten was talking
about in prime minister's questions is
whether or not boris johnson tells the
truth so we await from number 10 quite
how they're going to square what number
10 spokespeople were saying in
august september october november
december with what this email
bluntly shows in the cold light of day
and questions of propriety and honesty
at the dispatch box and in the media at
a point where there's loads of
uncertainty and it's just been pointed
out the downstream have again said they
still not have the sea grey report
indeed yes i was just going to sort of
say that so they the fact that they
haven't had it yet that suggests what
that it potentially could be published
today or do you know i think that's
really unlikely
i mean it could be a long day for all of
us it could come later tonight the
problem with the timing now is that um
parliament relies on a system of letting
mps know whether they're really going to
be required and there's what's known as
a one-line whip but which basically
means almost no mps are going to be here
tomorrow
very few people uh people are ever in
parliament on a friday so if not today
then could this extraordinary report
which determines the future of british
politics really hold until monday what's
the nature of the delay why is there
this delay over timing is it because
boris johnson doesn't want to publish it
all is there another reason that we
don't know about we just don't know but
i think we have to be prepared for
anything jane